so what is the point of sex I'm sure
that some if not all of you have some
ideas maybe you're thinking up a number
of original ingenious witticisms to
answer my question with and why not in
the millennia upon millennia of human
sexuality the act itself has become no
less fascinating or complicated or
fraught it has shaped our societies and
informed our art and yes it can also be
absurd and it can make you laugh we made
a whole episode about tardigrade sex and
there were a nonzero number of puns
while not all sex is reproductive today
we're gonna focus on sexual or
reproduction what's important to
remember in that context is that sexual
reproduction is not just some mechanical
process between individuals
it is also cellular and while that can
get lost in the mating habits of
metazoans protozoans are single-celled
eukaryotes contain many of the keys to
understanding how sexual reproduction
came to be because it's important to
remember that sex was an evolutionary
innovation a thing that at one point did
not happen and then began to happen and
the advantages of that caused sexual
reproduction to be carried over
throughout the eons up until today
[Music]
but the evolutionary history of sexual
reproduction is complicated and it is
mysterious and for an illustration of
why that is the case we're gonna turn to
amoebas those seemingly simple and
sexless eukaryotic blobs because it
turns out that amoebas aren't actually
that simple or even that sexless amoebas
are single-celled eukaryotes united by
the use of pseudopodia or false feet
that they use to move around and eat
they are distributed around various
eukaryotic lineages and we've talked
about just how tangled the taxonomic
classification of amoebas has become in
a previous episode and for a large part
of our scientific understanding and our
popular imagination amoebas have been
decidedly asexual in 1932 The New Yorker
published a poem called ode to the
amoeba composed by Arthur guy Turman a
writer known for his humor in the poem
he writes that first amoeba weirdly
clever exists today and shall forever
because he reproduced by fission he
split himself and each division and
subdivision deemed it fitting to keep on
splitting splitting splitting so what so
air they're billions be all all amoebas
still are he
now there are a lot of scientific
details in there that we could nitpick
but guy durman's poem helpfully and
delightfully lays out what has long been
the pervading image of amoebas an
ancient being that has sustained its own
individual identity by dividing into
clonal daughter cells those daughter
cells continue the process propagating
into other identical amoebas or serving
as the evolutionary basis for other
species that image of the amoeba as
primitive organism is itself linked to
what seems like an equally primitive
process asexual reproduction after all
if the existential goal of any organism
is to propagate their genetic
information then division seems simple
it's fast convenient and your new clone
should contain 100% of your genome but
there's a pretty big evolutionary
limitation with more and more divisions
an asexual organism will start to rack
up harmful mutations that will
eventually kill off a species this
process has a name it's called Muller's
ratchet and one way to avoid this
outcome is to take in foreign DNA a
strategy that bacteria and archaea
pursue in their own recombination
processes eukaryotes as we'll talk about
have sex
Muller's ratchet poses a conundrum for
our understanding of amoebas if the
theory holds then any asexual lineage of
organisms shouldn't last very long so
how do we square that with the image of
amoebas as an ancient line of organisms
the answer is simple we weren't wrong
about Muller's ratchet we were wrong
about amoebas
[Music]
let's start by defining sexual
reproduction at the cellular level
turning to a 2011 paper with the
wonderful title the chastity of amoeba
reevaluating evidence for sex and
amoeboid organisms in this work the
authors define sex as quote the presence
of a mitotic reduction of the genome
compliment followed eventually by Carrie
Agha me that is you know for us not the
set of words that we might use to
describe sex what it means is that
sexual reproduction involves two key
processes meiosis and nuclear fusion in
meiosis a cell divides distributing its
genetic material between its progeny
cells and reducing the number of
chromosome sets each cell contains after
those progeny cells find their mate the
next step is Carrie Agha me in this
process the cells fuse all the way down
to their nucleus thus increasing the
number of chromosome sets and providing
the basis for a whole new member of the
family in plants and animals that new
cell will then divide and divide and
develop into a multicellular organism
but in protozoans that new cell is the
organism like the recombination methods
employed by bacteria sexual reproduction
provides a mechanism for genetic
variability avoiding Muller's ratchet
but think of how complicated it must
have been to evolve this process which
is really the culmination of several
processes that altering of the number of
chromosomes the meiosis the nuclear
fusion not to mention the identification
of which organism to mate with meiosis
itself is so complex that it is
hypothesized to have evolved a single
time in the history of life on earth
based on genetic evidence that lasts
eukaryotic common ancestor that
mysterious evolutionary predecessor to
amoebas and all other eukaryotes relied
on sexual reproduction so if we know
that amoebas must be descended from a
sexual microbe and that the odds are low
on asexual amoebas lasting for long then
why has this image of the asexual amoeba
persisted for so long this
misunderstanding is a product of our own
observational challenges when it comes
to microbes the fact is that the gold
standard in confirming sex is the
ability to actually catch the organisms
in the act but that poses some clear
problems when amoebas and some other
microbes first and most obvious they are
tiny they can also be difficult to
cultivate in lab conditions particularly
in circumstances that might lead to sex
the slime mold Dictyostelium for example
was thought to be asexual until the
1970s when the scientists realized their
samples were just waiting for the right
mate to show up now aside from direct
observation we now have developed
genetic methods to determine whether an
organism might engage in sexual
reproduction this was the case for
cochlea podium an amoeba that was long
considered para sexual because it
followed some of the steps required for
sexual reproduction but it had never
been observed going through meiosis
instead in cochlea podium multiple cells
fused together to make a big cell with
several polyploid nuclei this mass then
breaks up to create cells with only one
nuclei so just imagine six people fused
together into a ball of goo and then
once again break apart into six more
individual people now all the children
of those original six it's a little more
complicated than the way we do it but
I'm not here to judge but in studying
cochlea podium further researchers found
that they
do have meiosis genes meaning they
probably do reproduce sexually we've
just never been able to see it
scientists have also found extensive
genetic evidence of sex in the amoebas
Oh a group of amoebas further
challenging the assumption that amoebas
are asexual and this introduces a
strange challenge we can't assume that
just because we haven't observed any
particular species having sex that it
must therefore be strictly asexual
because that's clearly not the case but
at the same time we cannot assume that
all eukaryotic life engages in sexual
reproduction because to do so would mean
blinding ourselves to other evolutionary
innovations to avoid Muller's ratchet if
there are strictly asexual amoebas then
that's a trait they evolved further away
from their ancestors perhaps finding an
alternative to sex that can negate some
of its downsides like needing to find a
good mate or risking the transmission of
disease and they wouldn't be alone
Deloitte rotifers are multicellular and
also asexual instead of relying on
sexual reproduction for recombination
they can acquire foreign DNA during
their resting and Hydra bios's state
which is wild some scientists have
hypothesized that asexual amoeba might
have their own strategies like relying
on having many many chromosomes to
reduce the harm of any mutation
so what's the point of sex well if we
look at amoeba it seems to be both
simple and unclear sex is a way to
create genetic variability but it is not
the only option
amoebas employ a wide range of sexual
and asexual life cycles some of which
we've been able to observe and
understand some of which we have not are
through guy Turman wrote another poem
called appropriately enough sex
it begins amoebas at the start were not
complex they tore themselves apart and
started sex we appreciate that guy
Turman was seemingly as preoccupied with
the reproductive habits of amoebas as we
are of course now we know that the
science underlying this stanza might not
be quite correct than amoebas were not
the beginners of sex but rather the
product of it just like sex itself is
not just a driver of evolution but a
result of it as well and that the loss
of sex might also be an evolutionary
strategy if anything looking at sex
through this lens seems like a reminder
that the amoebas at the start the ones
we might designate primitive are often
much more complex than we think
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us if you're glad that
there's a channel on YouTube that is
able to dive into the weird mating
habits of amoeba well the people on
screen are the folks you want to thank
for that
they are our patrons on patreon and if
you want to join them you can check us
out at patreon.com slash journey to
micro if you want to see more from our
master of microscopes james weiss check
out Jam and germs on instagram and if
you want to see more from us we are at
youtube.com slash micro cosmos